à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les le président de l'ukraine
et c'est son discours de la dernière
chance le pays est en crise
les yeux rivés sur la caméra il promet
d'unir son peuple sous une foule
d'applaudissements aussi break par el
hacen ce n'est que du cinéma
nous sommes sur le plateau de la très
populaire série de serviteurs du peuple
une satire politique dans laquelle le
comédien volodymyr zelensky incarne un
simple professeur devenu chef d'état du
jour au lendemain mais rarement l'arn
aura si bien imiter la réalité si les
sondages ne mentent pas l'humoriste lui
41 ans même dans la course la brède à la
présidence de l'ua semble zelensky s qui
souvent les questions ils n'aiment pas
donner d'entrevue il n'a pas encore de
programme concret
ils misent surtout sur sa célébrité son
expérience dans le milieu des affaires
qui ont fait de lui un millionnaire
indépendant de fortune mieux y aller
c'est moi
ce n'est pas terrible je n'ai pas besoin
de l'expérience de nos politiciens qui
détourne l'argent du peuple je suis un
homme d'affaires je dirige ma boîte de
production depuis 15 ans et j'ai une
équipe du tonnerre des ados il se veut
le candidat des jeunes urbains et leur
promet d'en finir avec la vieille
corruption qui se les institutions
craignait alors aux élèves qui je vais
voter pour lui parce qu'il est le
dernier espoir pour le pays doit aller
au boulot et c'est ce que font les
résidents de cette banlieue de kiev en
ce samedi matin et qui annonce le
printemps commence par les petites
choses comme ça dit si des gens qui
ramassent les mégots par terre dans leur
cour et sa voix jusqu'au président qui
va bien de faire son travail mais pour
lui confier la présidence
un homme qui se la joue à l'écran est
inconcevable et dangereux on est en
guerre on a des problèmes mais de
partout partout partout et l'iran gars
comme ça mais se sait se mettre une
balle dans la tête quoi tout simplement
cinq ans ont passé déjà depuis la
révolution du maidan qui a chassé le
président pro-russe viktor ianoukovitch
du pouvoir et depuis les progrès de
l'ukraine en vue d'accéder à l'union
européenne se comptent sur les doigts
d'une main
réforme de la police restructuration de
l'armée séparation de l'église orthodoxe
de celle de la russie
mais le bilan du président sortant petro
porochenko est loin loin de garantir sa
réélection
si ces rassemblements politiques au
désert de gloire dans les faits le
président est plus impopulaire que
jamais
ils baignent dans les scandales de
malversations et d'abus de pouvoir
il ya cinq ans j'ai pas voté pour lui
parce que certains ne les gars mais là
aujourd'hui il est capable de discuter
au même niveau avec les grands de ce
monde
rené boutinon aujourd'hui prochaine co
se rabat sur la continuité il somme les
ukrainiens de résister à toute tentative
de renouer les liens avec la russie mais
il ya encore bien vu leur nombre
iriez immeuble échappé à tokyo le ppcv
remarqué que galette jeunes filles
qu'avec bouvier qui change au destin
grygory nemyria est le principal
conseiller de la candidate ioulia
timochenko
la troisième force en présence de cette
élection qui a été le visage de la
révolution orange avec ses tresses déjà
première ministre et même prisonnière
politique a renouvelé son équipe et son
image aussi
elle nous a remis son cahier de
promesses qu'elle distribue partout aux
ukrainiens un programme plus odyssée
critiques qu'il a très peu populiste
quand je suis ce que je leur réponds
c'est que moi je vais remplir mes
engagements
le salaire moyen est de 300 dollars par
mois je vais construire une économie
européenne crédible
vous savez je suis en politique depuis
longtemps et je me suis toujours battu
contre le clan des corps ou dans l'autre
at il cette fois je gagnerai dit la
candidate qui profite pleinement du
désenchantement du peuple tout comme le
faisait lenski en attendant dans son
univers parallèle il répète son texte
pour la prochaine sans doute conscient
qu'il pourrait sous peu
gouverner un des pays les plus pauvres
les plus corrompus qu il est plus
fragile de leur a bien malins sont ceux
qui aujourd'hui peuvent prédire qui va
sera au prochain tour dimanche diogène
fin électeurs encore indécis
donc la démocratie en ukraine elle est
là quoi et c'est bien le seul consensus
qui se dégage aujourd'hui du terrain
mais pour l'ukraine des élections libres
et transparentes
c'est déjà une grande victoire en soi